the ncaa basketball tournament underway
in indianapolis has been around for more
than
80 years but another indy institution
has the tourney beat by
about four decades for many saint elmo
the james beard award-winning steakhouse
is the place to be seen during big
events in town
and the place to indulge in the classic
steakhouse experience
there's so much history just being in
this space it feels like
a trip inside saint elmo steakhouse is a
trip back in time
this is the original bar this is where
everybody came in
from 1902 still today tiger oak bar it's
been here
since day one if this bar could talk a
lot of people might be in trouble by now
yeah can you imagine craig hughes is one
of the current owners of this
indianapolis landmark just the third
ownership group
in a near 120 year history
starting with its founder joe starr this
was
the original room the only room at st
elmo back when it was joe starr's tavern
that tavern over time evolved into saint
elmo's steakhouse
harry roth and isidor rosen owned it
from 47-86
harry was an optometrist in chicago and
he said i went from from eyeglasses to
bar glasses and came down to help my
brothers
the brothers quickly moved on to
something but harry and izzy operated it
for a long time before my father bought
it in 1986.
eleven years later hughes partnered with
his dad
a veteran restaurateur in what's become
the family business
what was it about this place that spoke
to your father
he was a guest he loved it from from
your perspective sitting down
and got to know hearing izzy's and a lot
of the staff the employees here
he and i both feel like we're stewards
of this restaurant and we're here to
guide it throughout time that respect
for the past is obvious in every
aspect of saint elmo from its decor
to its food the menu is vintage
steakhouse
everything from a 22-ounce tomahawk
steak
to a 12-ounce fillet sides like king
crab mac and cheese
even decadent desserts like homemade
cheesecake
steakhouses traditionally are limited
menus anyway and they don't try to be
something to everybody right we just do
what we do
and it's a very clear identity of a
restaurant concept and it really
works well take its house specialty the
only appetizer on the menu
the saint elmo shrimp cocktail people
recognize it by
the fact that the cocktail sauce laden
with tons
of fresh ground horseradish just gets
stalled right on top of the shrimp
so how spicy should i be prepared for
familiar with the kick
i think you can handle this i couldn't
wait to dig in
no utensils required just grade
a large horseradish roots that get
ground
every single day here in the restaurant
it's so good
it's sinus clearing but i'm okay i'm
okay
the tradition of that shrimp cocktail
where does that come from
harry roth always shared with me that it
goes back as far as he knows
it was part of something they created
that kept people coming back
as evidenced by the very walls of saint
elmo
covered in its guests every photograph
that's on the wall is
someone that's dined here they come from
every celebrity industry that you can
imagine but sports certainly
trends very well with steakhouses
keeping tradition
is important at saint elmo as is staying
relevant
meaning subtle evolutions and additions
like this signature drink developed 10
years ago
the saint elmo cola this is our number
one
cocktail it's our whiskey that's infused
with italian luxardo cherries
vanilla and then we serve it with a
little glass bottle of coke on the side
it's an adult cherry cola but nothing st
elmo could do would
prepare it for this past year when we
had a snow day
in january i would be crushed we're not
going to be open we're not going to be
able to serve guests
and then when kova 19 comes around and
shuts the restaurant down for two and a
half
months just like how are we going to
survive that
events like march madness in
indianapolis a big help
in coming back from the pandemic the
restaurant is coming back and especially
due to this tournament
you're going to see it's going to be
like the light at the end of the tunnel
is now
all around us it's not at the end of the
tunnel it's we're out of the tunnel
why is it important for a place like
saint elmo to keep on going
restaurants like seeing elmo and those
restaurants all around the country that
are independent and have a history about
them help
give a town or a city a character an
identity
and a sense of place and hughes hopes
when it comes to saint elmo
that means a future as long as it's past
the restaurant has survived
two pandemics now uh prohibition
several world wars and and it just keeps
going on
my hope is that a hundred years from now
it's still going on and we're going to
leave in a better place you know
whatever time that
torch gets handed on to someone else
and i brought a little taste of st elmo
and indy to you
we have the famous st elmo shrimp
cocktail and the beverage as well
you've got to taste the sauce the sauce
it's the kick it's everything about it
everybody will tell you that's what you
have to have my dad lives in indy
saint elmo is great i'm so glad you did
this i'm so glad you brought this
right yeah and the taste of the beverage
cheers
i'll do this you do that
wow wow whoa
is it really that bad it's spicy you get
enough horseradish in there and the key
is
you don't want the horseradish sitting
in the sauce for too long
the fresher it is the spicier it is oh
wow i did learn that they wouldn't tell
me how much horseradish but they did
tell me that
we're inching closer to the o.g dishes i
know you know we're
just we're awesome
feels good